An 11,500-year old infant has been unearthed
in Alaska -- and “Sunrise Girl-Child’s”
DNA suggests that rather than several migratory
waves over time, all Native American ancestry
traces back to one massive migration.
And to breed plants that use water more efficiently,
researchers at Iowa State University are measuring
exactly how long it takes for corn plants
to move water from their roots to their leaves
using graphene plant tattoos.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
The world’s first photovoltaic expressway
has debuted in China.
Qilu Transportation Development Group has
built a 1-kilometer stretch of road that has
a bottom layer of insulation, a middle layer
of solar-powered batteries, and a top layer
of transparent concrete.
The electricity will power highway lights,
cameras, and signs -- but the developers are
hoping that it will power electric cars and
melt snow in the future.
But the cost is high -- it's $458 per square
meter compared to $5 for a standard asphalt
road -- and the 1 kilometer stretch will only
create enough electricity to power 93 homes
for one year.
So this has a long way to go before it becomes
like a thing.
Shrimp claws took 150 million years to develop.
A study of 114 species of shrimp has revealed
how they’re able to snap their claws.
Researchers at the University of Alberta found
what they call ‘extreme biology’ -- shrimp
evolving to make use of an air vacuum that
stores and expends energy… in a snap.
Shrimp use the snapping motion to communicate,
attack prey, and defend themselves.
So that 150 million years was totally worth
it.
And shrimp are delicious.
Millions of diabetics could benefit from a
skin-like surface.
Currently, diabetics have to prick their skin
to monitor blood sugar levels -- not only
is it painful, but it can result in infections
and other complications.
But researchers at in Beijing have found that
ultra-thin, skin-like biosensors can reliably
monitor glucose levels in a non-invasive way
-- which means more comfort and better monitoring.
20 years ago, Apopo started training “Hero
Rats” to detect landmines and diagnose tuberculosis
-- and they’re getting more efficient.
It takes 4 days for a lab technician to evaluate
100 samples of sputum or for a minesweeper
to cover an area the size of a tennis court.
A Hero Rat can do either job in just 30 minutes.
Research and development includes teaching
rats to indicate the presence of mines by
flipping a collar switch and identifying the
presence of new diseases.
So thanks, rats.
We tend to think of robots as rigid, metal
creations -- for now.
The Keplinger Research Group at the University
of Colorado is developing ‘soft’ robots
that mirror the makeup and movements of biological
muscle tissue.
Soft robotics allows machines to be as forceful
or gentle as they need to be, and researchers
say the muscle-like electrical actuators that
make industrial and commercial applications
possible can be produced now for about 10
cents.
Humanity has milked its first platypus.
The male platypus has a venomous spur on its
hind feet that it uses to compete with other
males for mates, but until now, no one has
extracted the venom.
Tim Faulkner of the Australian Reptile Park
successfully took a sample of venom which
includes a hormone that may be useful in treating
diabetics.
The world’s first DJ robot is spinning in
the Czech Republic.
A club in Prague challenged robotics manufacturer
KUKA to make a robotic arm that controls the
action and can respond to the crowd.
And the challenge was accepted.
But the robot music revolution isn’t happening
quite yet -- the club is alternating between
human and robot DJs every hour.
Do tiny sea turtles that hatch on the beach
get tired when they don’t make it to the
water quickly enough?
Researchers at Florida Atlantic University
put them on a treadmill to find out.
Sea turtles crawl toward the light, which
means urban glows can disorient them.
FAU researchers found that the turtles crawl,
rest, and keep crawling even after hours of
effort.
They’re little crawling machines and as
a wise zombie child once said, “I like turtles.”
At Columbia University’s Robotics and Rehabilitation
Lab, exoskeletons are helping train people
to walk again....
The goal is to be able to build and design
lightweight, wearable exoskeletons.
An exoskeleton that doesn't have explicit
joints that can either assist them in their
movement or train them so that they can eventually
walk without these exoskeletons.
To come up with novel inventions in science
and technology, we need to develop our own
toolkits and frameworks for understanding,
instead of blindly memorizing formulas.
Brilliant's interactive problems are a great
way for you to really understand math and
science.
They have everything from Number Theory, to
Mastering Casino Blackjack, or this one I
really like that explains Solar Energy from
the ground up - we all know that solar panels
absorb the Sun's energy, but what is it that
they actually do?
So click the link at the top of the description
to get 20% off your annual subscription.
Your brain will thank you.
Now I’m gonna leave you with an ANYmal robot
which greets a new friend in an interesting
way…
You'll see.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Small calculator, a really silent electronic,
a really fast thinker, one that works anywhere
on battery or plug-in.
One with all the calculator know-how you'll
probably ever need.
Introducing, the world's smallest electronic
calculator from the maker of the world's most
complete line, Sharp.
Introducing the ELSI-8 -- the world's smallest
electronic calculator by Sharp.
A price tag to match.
$345, complete.
ELSI-8 -- the answer.